These views are called State Transition Diagrams, they're essentially represent,
graphical representations of a Finite State Machines.
In these diagrams we have an indication of a node, typically with an oval,
or some kind of rectangle. We have arcs, directed arcs connecting the nodes,
indicating that there's a state transition. The arcs can be labeled.
The arcs can be labeled with an action and a transition.
Typically the actions can be can be optional. Usually,
but not always, the transitions are, are not optional, okay? If you recall
your finite state machines from theory, there are these epsilon transitions.
We'll see in fact that the garage door opener has one of these, but they're,
they're not, they're not all that typical. Note that the layout of the nodes,
where we placed them in the diagram, doesn't have any semantic import. So
you are free to make the diagram lay it out in a way that conveys what you
consider to be the important behavioral aspects of the system. In terms of
how these diagrams work, you can think of yourself as, at any point in time,
being in a specific state. Okay, kind of waiting there until an event happens.
When the event happens, the outgoing arcs are examined to determine
whether any of them are labeled with the corresponding event.
And if so, a transition is made between the current state and
the state at the end of that transition. And in so
doing the action, if any, on that transition arc is, is executed.